you know when to walk up this video
playing damned jan 04 okay um I think
you're such a six guy he's not okay I
was thinking it to some good fouled I
know I winfelder king's indian standard
some classical limbs oh I have played
them a lot 8 out of 11 is the score yeah
black in this position is to get to find
the pawn structure somehow if he wants
to play like this or d 5 or whatever
couple of options Bishop c5 this is not
seen so often in this position I don't
think that's a particular reason for
that okay I think I'll just develop 96
is the most common move I think it well
this might be a situation where I don't
have to play the move a 3 quite often a
3 as a mandatory move in the line for
Quincy tool and then 45 and i had i did
not have to play this now maybe i can
get by without a three i will try that
oh interesting decision
hmm and it could be very dangerous this
is very comparable to a queen's gambit
bishop f form but no the bishop was on
g5 so I wonder I wonder where his
compensation is see if I play the norms
and light before I forgot one night
before ok it doesn't do it ok I was
thinking just takes you right and Queen
takes 95 is that really compensation for
the pawn hmm hmm how to believe that ok
so here I'm taking i guess and going to
be 30 Queen to d2 this is also almost 22
okay if I go 22 let's say five but
should be talked to 894 look save look
save queen bee three the run into tempe
with a five and Bishop you six I guess
so probably 3 2 D 2 a.m. okay i think
i'll start with 94 I have to go here
anyway to shield on the D file and if I
go Bishop e2 first he might have no
chief form I sorry bishop chief form so
i start with this maybe 96 is an option
just getting rid of the night quickly
maybe
okay I think of flicking age 3 this is
and probably useful in most cases i
can't play g4 here maybe g4 and Bishop
g2 and Sam it looks slightly loose
though suppose my principal alternative
let's do it Bishop b5 I want to be ready
for knight c6 so that I can may be
captured with the bishop and I castle
long short next HP bishop edge five
after Bishop age five there is no
possible sacrifice on age three or so if
you would have gone or stayed on that
diagonal on the c8 g for the anger and
so King fields relatively safe here
I have to be careful about the bishop a
bit on b5 we feel somehow attack subs it
would hang us on sds is pinned on the D
file and I'd currently had this one
Trenton screen takes b5 ok so i can play
hope it should be too disruptive form
there for some funny tactics some funny
tactics going on here
and there might be some look to for
Bishop f3 in some cases interesting okay
so what am I playing is not so easy yeah
I was thinking a three maybe yeah let's
do this is a technical solution unless
I'm miscalculating it Queen B 5 I wanted
to take on B form rock t420 for queuing
b5 shouldn't work OOP the [ __ ] windy for
Bishop f three years I've got g3 I don't
think this would work and maybe anyway
we'll see what happens the tactical a
tricky situation maybe he can no I've
got before that's six I can take with
the bishop angle B form okay it takes
quite a while him kind of curious what
he was going to do this one okay here at
least that's easy too easy to respond um
okay um we should have three years the
move that irritates me d play here so
maybe this one I'm taking other night
you should have 3 i've got bishop f1 so
this is now quite quite neat
time morning Cory should take it Goldie
8 and it's not a move you and you are
really keen on playing
Bishop t2 i just want to trade this
thing good move Annoying move currently
I controlled CNT file which is very
important yeah he's probably not making
the time here how to do this here can I
do something on the Queen maybe g4 here
and doesn't have a check go into his six
black yeah he was a bit too slow here
losing on time one move 30 um okay so
what happened here the additive 50 was
very surprising it looks so looks a bit
bit premature however after I captured I
don't think that the capture is actually
right because his co he can good night
before the possibility that he did not
use that this was a probably see if I
was a bad decision here I think black
should be fine no I mean I can I can do
this or whatever but he's fine yeah I
think okay baby Bishop c4 well maybe
just this yeah this is fine for black
that's fine for black the problem here
is simply that it sits upon and the
compensation is probably not completely
sufficient check and he has some but I'm
kind of reluctant to believe that is
enough
this a five looks normal and 94 as I
think the most precise something like
this gives gives black additional
options like this kind of thing and this
is this is probably more precise that I
have also this movie fifth if necessary
so let's say rook the aid this is
something that I saw during the game of
this 926 I can take and go here and now
I have a target down it's a sharp
position i can go Quincy file and stuff
but it was my idea you know flick this
end ok interesting Bishop f5 is given by
the comp and stronger yeah that's not
not a surprise yeah this is if you look
at this this is also getting this idea
into the game in fact this is actually a
move yeah very nice completely unclear
position here like black has enormous
play here it I can just just web stuff
yet and equalize completely maybe there
was something better for you yeah
there's some interesting possibilities
and here yeah I feel I should be better
Mia me engine is on 0.8 and here it
wants to go what does it want to do a
form yeah I didn't want to do that in
three I don't think a three is bad would
be I will be surprising the ibook g4 is
the best according to the comp and now
not this one but we should have three
and this now can the Queen d7 home ok so
this is bad it seems to to community
forum yeah okay this is a very
cold-blooded move of course in this and
then take on b7 it's good though once
you see it you can def way I can only
agree with the engine and it's just of
course making sense 12 points okay this
I play it and this must impress I he has
to do this first I think and maybe maybe
here there's something else then there
or let's say he has to capture this is
and now something else so that now I
have g 3n 25 maybe know there is a
tricky game as a tricky position can
looks at this and what am I doing here
it's not easy rookie one to get out of
this you will take him as so kind of
okay for black so Queenie for was a lot
stronger but I was unhappy that that he
didn't take this opportunity here I'm
essentially really just a pawn up but ok
it was kind of yeah that he had a huge
time problem a here and lost on time it
is some some Queen Anne Chang this kind
of position now White has very good
winning chances but it's always
difficult to say in a queen ending if it
says it's a definite win it's good
chances but unclear but is enough okay
well thanks for watching